Let's also look at examples of what focal length does in terms of
what viewpoint do you want to capture.
Here I'm showing two examples.
Again, our two friends that have come visited us before, and
here I've basically shown two images.
This image was captured with a focal length of 18 millimeter on
a 35 millimeter sensor.
That was a full frame camera.
Distance to the first subject is half a meter, and
distance to the second subject was two meters.
In this case, I used a focal length ten times as larger 180mm.
Again, the same camera.
And, the distance to the first subject is no longer 0.5,
but I moved 2.5 meters away.
And, of course, that meant the distance to the second subject is also now
2.5 meters more, 4.5.
Exactly the same scene,
shot by two different focal lengths with the same camera.
And you can note this that each one of them has a different impact.
What this shows is that changing the focal length allows us to move back and
still capture the entire scene.
But, of course, changing this form of a viewpoint also does change
a perspective change.
For example,
these two scientists are appearing to be actually much closer than they are.
They are actually almost 1.5 meter apart.
But by looking at this image, you can't tell.
They almost look to be sitting next to each other.
One of the best ways to kind of visualize this is to see the vertigo effect.
I recommend you look it up on YouTube.
But this kind of scene perspective tricks are widely used in
movies like The Lord of the Rings trilogy, where you could see Gandalf and
Frodo sitting next to each other, but looking much different sizes.
Of course, there's still approximately same human size, but
in case Frodo looks much shorter.
And this is exactly the kinds of tricks that were done in movies like this,
by basically moving farther away and
using a high-focal length lens to kind of show them to be different sizes.
So this is the kind of tricks again that are widely used in movie industry.
But just by changing the focal length we can actually change the perspective
and the viewpoint.